with the help of Telus International the
sponsors of this segment are great toy
drive starts tomorrow and goes to the
16th and Karen Muniz is uh with Telus is
here to tell us to tell us more to help
it was gonna it was bound to happen
about tell us what do you guys do yeah
so we're a global organization comprised
of over 70 000 team members across 28
countries wow and we deliver Next
Generation digital and customer
experience solutions for different top
Global Brands okay I'm sure you've
worked with some toy brands possible
yeah we have yeah one of the one of the
main things that's very important to
tell us is being able to give back to
the local communities where our team
members work and where they live so
we're very excited to be participating
and sponsoring the great toy drive for
that very reason absolutely well on
behalf of Channel 8 thank you guys for
sponsoring it for us we're excited to
see how many toys we can give to the
community
um now you guys have a unique caring
culture I've heard about tell us more
about that and and you know how that
process is during within your company we
do we do it's very much one of our core
values we always strive to build
stronger communities in the locations
where we have our different sites we
want to make sure that we're building
strong communities and participating in
different voluntary initiatives in order
to improve those communities
um you know the core values that we have
and our brand promise of we give where
we live is very near and dear to our
team members Hearts so we always strive
to continue that message absolutely and
Beyond you know charity like the great
toy drive you got diversity inclusivity
you know you want to make sure you're
touching on all things within Telus so
thank you for that now how can people
donate donate to the toy drive
specifically your location and then of
course you bring toys to us as well yeah
definitely so as of tomorrow anyone can
stop by our location we're at 2251 South
Decatur Boulevard and you can stop by
during business hours and drop off any
new unopened toys while you're there you
can also stop by our recruiting office
we're always looking to grow and hire
new people so would love to to meet new
people to join our amazing team as well
that's awesome that's good to know now
when they do stop by your facility or
for your offices what should they expect
what are they going to see what's what's
going on in there yeah so it's just
right in the front lobby they'll be our
amazing customer service team right up
front to greet them the donation bin is
right there front and center so it's
very very easy to find okay yeah very
friendly people will be there to kind of
help guide the way as well well it
sounds like a good team to be a part of
if you guys are you know looking for
jobs out there another way you're giving
back to the community absolutely you
know we started Carlos Las Vegas
operation in 2008 with just a few
hundred team members and we've been able
to offer many more job opportunities so
now we're at nearly 2 000 team members
in Las Vegas well thank you thank you so
much Karen that is great and tomorrow
starts the great toy drive so thank you
to Telus International for sponsoring
this segment and it's going until the
16th and benefits the shade tree as well
in Las Vegas now we'll be right back